jose or kitty on the mound tonight for
houston
his eighth start of the season oh and
two on jose or kitty
and a swing and a miss or kitty making
quick work of shohei ohtani a
three-pitch strikeout to start the game
swing and a miss 94 mile an hour
fastball gets him
her kitty has two strikeouts to start
this game of the first three batters
one and two the count swing and a miss
94
right down the middle and guys are
swinging underneath it or kitty strikes
out
all three of the outs in the first
inning a single in the mix
andrew rohini getting ready to work as
we go to the bottom of the first
inning jose altuve has a lot of it bats
in his career against hiney
25 in all and he's a 400 hitter 10 for
25
against andrew as he delivers a high fly
ball deep to left field on the first
pitch of the game and this ball
is off the foul pole home run jose
altuve
altuve hits his fourth home run of the
year and on one pitch
the astros on the board altuve springing
the astros into the lead
doing the work on hini you know he
throws a lot of first pitch strikes you
know out two they seen him a lot
and you knew there was a possibility
there would be an ambush and he got him
no there's a strong combination that
that algorithm you just came up with is
what added up to that big swing from
jose altuve
that balls hit hard over the jumping
jose rojas in the right field that paul
was a bullet that rojas almost robbed
him of a hit but you're not
a two out base runner two outs jordan on
first base here's yuli guriel
uli drives one to right field sending
ward back he's at the wall
he will watch this one go yuli guriel
his third career home run against the
lefty andrew heaty
he saw 10 pitches and liked the final
one the most
and gives the astros a three to nothing
lead
it's la pina season
this guy's been unbelievable
[Applause]
i always do a slider every single 3-2
count by the way
jose rojas sends a ball out to right
field that'll check up against defense
and rojas kicks
in the second with a lead-off double
i don't know no idea i'm guessing it's
western pa though it's probably
pittsburghy
and a swing and a miss by mccormick so
he goes down on strike second punch out
for hiney tonight
i've had some fans upset with
swing and a miss dropped in the breaking
ball for a strikeout that's four for a
kitty first time through the lineup
last night the show was on and it was
ohtani he went seven innings strong
scattered four hits kyle tucker got him
with
there's no way those guys are gonna get
talked out of a lineup and it doesn't
matter if there's any change in the
pitching staff they're ready to go no
matter who it is because they feel
comfortable against the team
a rare strikeout for brantley as he's
unable to hold up that's three
strikeouts for hiney tonight
all hit off the end of the bat but kyle
tucker is going to make a diving play
kind of changed gears a couple of times
while that ball was in the air and put
it away for the first
out might have been moving a little bit
but kyle tucker luckily made the
adjustment
out there
that's not what you want to see not at
all
i didn't see anything on that last
delivery got that fly out
taylor ward oh boy they're gonna call
for somebody
they're going to call for dusty i think
to talk
about what he wants to do here so carlos
correa doing a lot of the talking and
may have convinced
strami that her kitty should not go
this is interesting
lee meyer the assistant athletic trainer
standing next to jose or kitty
see correa taking up the conversation
again
and that might be it this is difficult
to figure out because he's been rolling
along three and two thirds innings
of shutout baseball has looked good
throughout
had you you said you hadn't seen
anything the velocity has been about the
same right
yeah all right we'll try and figure some
things out but
disappointing to see jose or kitty leave
this game
as he faces 13 batters tonight
and retires 11 of them archite will
leave
with two outs here in the fourth inning
three nothing astros and guriel is the
batter and he swings at the first pitch
and pops one down the right field side
coming hard
after it is the right fielder ward going
back on it is walsh and walsh will make
the catch on that ball
as he and ward nearly uh knocked each
other down they both ended up hitting
the deck on that one but
no real hard collision over there so
nice play there by
the uh first baseman jared walsh he was
on a mission to make the catch on that
one
here's haney's one-two pitch and a swing
and a miss he got him
change-up struck out mccormick for the
second time tonight
getting a report on jose or kitty from
the astros clubhouse that he has
posterior shoulder discomfort in his day
to day
he didn't notice a tick down in velocity
but
not comfortable out there on the mound
and he leaves the game after three and
two thirds innings
off of heeney towards first base
nobody's gonna be able to make this play
michael brantley with an infield hit
[Music]
on the ground and that's going to find
an open space between
iglesias and rojas
[Applause]
not a lot of margin for error popped him
up
and playable for goslin to get
heeney out of a tight spot in the fifth
the astros have a one out base runner
kyle tucker the batter over two flat out
to deep center
his last time tucker
high and deep to right field forget
about it
way into the upper deck kyle tucker
home run number eight on the season
astros tack on
two more it's now a five-nothing lead
up and in
[Applause]
and a huge kyle driver from the top
turnbuckle out there in right field
[Applause]
it'll be butera to bat against the new
reliever here runners at the corners and
nobody out
the uterus ends of all the center field
playable for mccormick
it's going to tag up gosling and bring
him in to score and the angels are on
the board in the eighth
alvarez who's one for three with a
single under run
that ball is crushed deep to right field
you're
todd alvarez second deck home run
his seventh of the year astros have
scored all their runs tonight on the
home run
it's now a six to one game
fans know their stroke gosh yeah he's
now got 18 here at minutemate park and
that was a changeup center cut
and obliterated correa at third tucker
at first six to one astros one out
bottom of the eight chaz mccormick at
the plate oh for three
that ball's drilled deep to left field
chas
mccormick three run home run
astros with a fourth spot here in the
eighth
lead this game nine to one
speaking of getting ready to fire
there's a cannon shot off the bat at
chas mccormick
103.8 miles an hour
pitch on the way ground ball bounce left
side coming on corey he's got it slings
to first in time and that is the ball
game houston astros hit five homers
and take the rubber game of this series
from the angels by a final
of nine to one